all right welcome everybody to stream
number two today did a stream earlier
today with the anthony fauci dr.
Redfield Stephen Hahn doctor of Admiral
Gerar and did a few hours of that did
today's broadcast show and podcast did
today's members only bonus show and now
we are back again just sixteen to a
hundred minutes depending on how late
she is today the latest press briefing
from Donald Trump's press secretary
Kelly Mackin Annie we are monitoring any
number of different feeds scheduled to
start at the top of the hour and glad to
be back with you my prediction is this
stream might be a little wackier than
the then than the last one although I
have to say 20 new members last stream
nothing to sneeze at for a stream that
started when it was still 6:00 in the
morning on the west coast of the United
States if you can imagine let me answer
and address a few super chats and then
I've got some clips to play for you
we're going to look at testing numbers
people Oh I said yesterday that I
believe my hair is long enough to
actually make a ponytail right now
I've got in in the back I don't know if
you can see it hold on let me see here
there is see how there's a there's a
fistful in the back I could make that
into a ponytail and I promise to
yesterday if we got 250 members but we
did not we didn't so then that's that's
it you know if I just give it all the
way for free I'm training people in the
I'm reinforcing next havior to use a
Pavlovian term but in any case it's
there's no ponytail today although it is
theoretically possible okay super chats
that have come in nasty questions says
we are so lucky to have to David Pakman
streams today yes yes zesty African says
Dave Pakman more like Dave ping ping
ding ding er what's your favorite movie
from the last year I don't even know I
barely watch movies my favorite movie
from the last year I don't I just I
don't even know I just rarely watch
movies i watch documentaries in series
real I have to think about that
thanks to Nick to gamer for signing up
on YouTube Cyrus Palmer or ceruse Palme
apartment Palmer says here comes the
bragging about testing downplaying the
threat and attacks on journalists who
asked real questions yeah Kaylee's last
press briefing started like 40 minutes
late and lasted 22 minutes was it 23
minutes something like it'sit's a joke
what's going on most transparent
administration they claim to be
absolutely bonkers let me say thank you
to John umber John umber has just signed
up at join pakman.com and his new member
number one today appreciate that John
let's see here a TJ says any traction to
the rumor of Trump's association with a
missing hooker in New York in the late
90s I don't know if that's real but I've
never heard about that before Ken Clive
says embrace your inner wasteland er and
let the hair grow Dave I don't have a
choice I mean there's no there's no
haircut in sight for me right now
Nathaniel Haney has grabbed a YouTube
membership
Sam Dean says g'day dave 344 in the
morning here in Melbourne Australia good
luck great to see you Sam Sam seems to
keep pretty late hours there I'll tell
you that want to say thanks also to be
see chip for subscribing with twitch
prime as well as invalid axiom ferry
Tigers any greenfield and meticulous
seven Wow a lot of action a lot of
action over on twitch okay I I'm going
to review as I tend to do the latest
coronavirus official numbers we are at
4.3 million
confirmed cases globally and we are
approaching 300,000 global deaths okay
yesterday we had 74 thousand new cases
and 34 hundred new deaths if we look at
new cases we see that Russia and Brazil
are to dramatically growing hot spots UK
has beaut USA and UK have been up there
for a while India is the other one okay
so we look at Russia as you can see this
is not
the trajectory you want things are
getting very quickly very bad in Russia
if you look at Brazil notice by the way
both of these places have whacked
authoritarian leaders Brazil is not not
going particularly well as the curve
goes to lower days which may be related
to two weekends a lot of countries have
lower reporting on weekends and you can
kind of see that in Prior numbers Brazil
is not looking particularly good and
then India was not testing for a very
long time so we don't really know like
are things actually getting that much
worse in India or is it that they're now
testing it's probably a combination of
both but things not looking good in
India either in the United States we now
have just shy of 1.4 million cases
remember that on a pop on a per
population basis we have 4.2 percent of
the world's population and about a third
of all the cases we are now at 80 2555
deaths and once again if we look at new
cases yesterday we are seeing that New
York California Illinois and New Jersey
are still at the top in the raw number
of new cases but they have dramatically
declined from their peaks on the other
hand you have places like Virginia Texas
Maryland was an early place Ohio
Tennessee which were not early hotspots
that now regularly have some of the most
new cases per day so things criss
crossing some of the early states doing
better some of these states that didn't
really take closing seriously are now
starting to get dramatically worse very
very much worse in terms of testing
yesterday we did three hundred and
eighty eight thousand tests that's great
that's I believe the most we've ever
done other than I think there was like
one day somewhere in here and it might
have been an anomaly and I don't even
see it that's good remember that we need
to add a minimum get to 500,000 today
and most experts believe we need to be
somewhere in the range of a million to a
million and a half tests per day we're
currently about 39th I believe in
per-capita testing globally so that's
the update there and
basically you now have all of the latest
testing information that I have the test
numbers are at co vid tracking dot org
if anybody wants to see that and then
you can also find per capita testing
numbers by country on the world ah
meters dot info website welcome to
everybody who's watching on Twitter
twitch YouTube Facebook and mixer today
hello mixer really appreciate you
joining me and we are just ten ten
minutes away from the official start
time of today's White House press
briefing with a Caylee Mackin Annie
Trump's press secretary other super
chats are coming in and I would love for
you to send a question or a comment if
you're watching on YouTube via super
chat mark Jillian says we'll love to see
the reaction of the Trump administration
when the reopening goes out of control I
mean listen I hope it doesn't happen but
it's not looking good in some of these
states
Seth Barham says hi David I just
witnessed my neighbor commit
first-degree Obama gage should I report
it to the FBI or the local police I
believe that that's a federal issue yeah
let's actually get to that real quick
some of the key moments from yesterday's
press briefing here is Donald Trump
being asked by trigger er in chief
Phillip Rucker of the Washington Post
Phillip Rucker excellent at triggering
Trump take a look at this my friends
it's wacky
strap in for this one
mr. president and one of your mother's
day tweets you appear to accuse
president Obama of the biggest political
crime in American history by far those
were your words
what crime exactly are you accusing
President Obama of committing and do you
believe the Justice Department should
prosecute him Obama game it's been going
on for a long time
Trump Trump has been the victim of the
crime of Obama Gate for a long time it's
been going on from before I even got
elected and it's a disgrace that it
happened and if you look at what's gone
on and if you look at happened oh the
crime of Obama gate happened get now all
of this information that's being
released and from what I understand
that's only the beginning some terrible
things happened and it should never be
allowed to happen in our country again
it should listen it's illegal it's been
happening for a long time it was
terrible and it should never be allowed
to happen again what though oh yeah
Obama gate Obama gate and you'll be
seeing what's going on over the next
over the coming weeks but and over the
coming period of time we're going to be
looking at it very closely we should
write honestly about it but
unfortunately you choose not to do so
yeah John please what if the crime
exactly you know what the crime is the
crime is very obvious to everybody when
you have to do is read the newspapers
except yours right John play every
newspaper but the Washington Post is
talking about it and then here is the
climax and subsequent day Newmont of
yesterday's press briefing we're going
to first see CBS correspondent Wei Jia
Jiang asked why everything's a
competition for Trump while people are
dying
followed by CNN's Caitlyn Collins
triggering Trump into abandoning the
press briefing Trump ragequitting as the
term maybe yeah go ahead please
many times that the u.s. is doing far
better than any other country when it
comes to testing yes
why does that matter why is this a
global competition to you if everyday
Americans are still losing their lives
and we're still seeing more cases every
day well they're losing their lives
everywhere in the world and maybe that's
a question you should ask China now
understand think about her question why
is everything a competition for you when
people continue to die he says go ask
China that that question why why first
of all there's two interpretations ask
China why everything is a competition
for Trump
what would China know about that or ask
China why everything is a competition
for them which it doesn't seem to be
because we're not hearing from China
that they have the best and most testing
it's a weird question don't ask me has
China that question okay when you ask
them that question you may get a very
unusual answer yes behind you please
yeah the unusual answer would be I don't
know we're not bragging about being the
best of testing what sir why are you
saying that to me specifically I'm
telling you I'm not saying it
specifically to anybody I'm saying it to
anybody that would ask a nasty question
like that please go ahead
alrighty then brace yourselves okay
anybody else please go ahead in the back
please it's okay
I have two questions mister next next
place that you didn't you called on me I
did and you didn't respond and now I'm
calling on just a young lady in the back
please okay ladies and gentlemen thank
you very much appreciate quit thank you
very much I'll buy all deaf for and
there he goes
extremely extremely special snowflake
Donald Trump to apply its term that I
don't even use like I don't even use
that term but we're just you know they
they use it and we are showing how have
ridiculous of a thing to say it is so
there it is
Trump bailing and that that I think is
why it is not a particularly good idea
for Trump to do the press briefings and
he's been doing them less and less
frequently and I think that is probably
probably smart people getting banned on
Twitch I love it all right very good
there have the moderators have not had
to drop the ban hammers too much
recently on YouTube nor on twitch but I
am seeing that the ban hammer is being
dropped I am curious what what went down
I'm sure it was ugly but anyway yeah
remember even though that the moderators
are sparing with the ban hammer use they
will use it when it is required and they
are fully deputized in order to do it
and by the way we you've got to do
something pretty damn bad to get banned
from my YouTube or twitch channels and
yeah anyway okay other super chats
coming in zesty African says from the
standpoint of water Obama gate is real
absolutely
Carl Smith says do you think Trump would
go so far as to make up evidence and
getting his corrupt Republican senators
to charge Obama with fake evidence
I don't know that Trump would make up
evidence but it would not shock me to
see Trump push the Justice Department to
bring some kind of bogus political
charges against Donald Trump against
Barack Obama I'm not predicting it would
happen but if it did it would not be
beyond this president and that's a scary
thing
Marc Fillion says of course nobody wants
the reopening to go out of control but I
was just curious to see the lies that
will be used to blame somebody else
yeah I understand absolutely absolutely
I want to welcome a very special person
on twitch beryllium poisoning has just
subscribed with twitch Prime with the
message a beautiful inspiring message of
peace and love
lilium poisoning says my boy deepak okay
excellent
excellent when okay so I see people are
tuning in and wondering what's going on
we are just waiting for the start of
Caylee McKenna knees press briefing we
it's scheduled for essentially now but
we don't know exactly when it will start
usually does anybody know if there's a
stream that's live in the room right now
usually Fox cuts to a shot of the press
briefing room in advance of of the press
briefing and they haven't which does not
bode particularly well to us
oh there's people who are only here
until Caylee starts speaking okay that's
fair but if anybody's in the room like
if Washington Post has a stream that's
going live let's see if I can find one
is I'd like to get a sense of how how
close we are to starting maybe
Washington Post you know they don't see
you oh by the way if you are just
joining please make sure that on youtube
you've liked the stream that's extremely
important no I'm not seeing that
anybody's live in the room let me just
check Washington Post post
live no no they are not live either so I
guess we're we're sort of on our own as
the case may be for the time being but
we will we will keep an eye on that
charlie says via super chat trump is so
alpha that he completely lost it and ran
offstage yeah my thoughts exactly
oh people are asking if I if I've seen
the Andrew yang Sam Harris podcast I
only saw a clip of the section about
this is the Fox stream for people who
are telling me to look at Fox it's
literally says Fox on the screen I did
see Andrew yang talking about the Joe
Biden dementia stuff and some Tara Reid
stuff and I mean I basically agree with
Andrew Yang's perspective and I may have
more to say about it at some point in
the future but basically agree with with
most of what Andrew yang said there Sam
Dean says what statement would you like
to send to your overseas partners
regarding these crazy times we know this
rubbish doesn't truly represent
yes the message is give us an
opportunity to make this right give us
an opportunity to do the right thing and
remove Donald Trump in November if we
don't then I understand if you know
American flights aren't allowed to go
into other countries I mean like
understand the way things are going
Spain has it Spain's curve is dropping
France is dropping Germany's dropping
Italy's dropping South Korea's barely
even rose we are not handling this well
and you could very much have a situation
in a month or two where travel between
the UK and Japan is back on travel
between Canada and Europe is back on and
Americans wouldn't be allowed to go to
these places because we simply are not
dealing with it the way that they are it
it's going to get very very ugly and I
still don't know that trumpets word say
okay Trump failed we fight we finally
have to say it Trump failed I don't know
I think even then they may still stand
behind him David Hillary says thanks
again for all you do appreciate it David
thank you very much Kevin mccomber says
why would Medicare for all be better
than a public option Oh Kevin a we have
a hundred clips about this stuff on the
YouTube channel I'm not I'm not gonna go
off into that right now especially just
just minutes from the start of today's
today's press briefing but if you're
curious my take on those types of issues
we have endless endless videos about
that on the David Pakman show YouTube
channel very very important stuff um
chess tournament yes we are going to do
another David Pakman show chess
tournament soon don't know when it's
just there's so many streams and so much
stuff going on oh hold on somebody said
they found the podium live but links
aren't allowed can you just describe how
to find a live shot of the podium if
anybody can tell me what to search on
YouTube like it do I type in you know
Washington Post live briefing or what
what do I search for the time YouTube
page love it time press briefing live
love it absolutely love it
although I'm not easily finding it I'm
finding archives uh here it is beautiful
appreciate that
let's now get that element triggered on
the screen and here it is excellent
alright we are about to be live in the
room and it's gonna be tremendous it's
gonna be unbelievable here we go
ah there we go alright very good so we
are getting very very close let me
mention just one time if you will
indulge me it's it's interesting the
less I talk about membership people seem
more interested in signing up and we
don't even have to spend much time
talking about it all of the work we do
this morning stream this stream the
podcast the broadcast show the bonus
show the TV show the radio show the
clips the folds all this stuff it's
mostly funded because a few of you we
estimate about 0.8 percent of our
audience goes to my website and get some
membership okay if we could go from
point eight percent of the audience
supporting us to one point five percent
it would be a game-changer so I invite
you grab a membership at join pakman.com
not only will I thank you so profusely
but you can also take advantage of a 66%
discount with the coupon code 2020 now
this is winning
okay these are elements of winning that
are available on the website and I know
a lot of people twenty percent of the
country nearly is now unemployed a lot
of people have cancelled 722 in a p-- in
March and April we're here for you for
free that we're producing either way but
if you are in the field of people that
can afford a couple bucks a month to
subsidize all that we do for everybody I
would really appreciate it it's not a
lot for lots of people if it is then I
don't want your money
okay I froze there for a second but
we're back but I really do appreciate
everybody who's been supporting the
streams and everybody gets a thank you
don't worry about it
okay let's see here Donna Williams says
who should Biden select for vice
president I've kind of been leaning
towards Elizabeth Warren lately I have
to be honest I've been leaning towards
Elizabeth Warren I think that that that
would be quite interesting from the Stan
point of voting but he said he was going
to select a woman so I think at this
point he probably has to make good on it
would be my sense of it okay let's see
here Quarry keen whoa
Quarry keen says do you think we should
be sanitizing our streets no I think
that makes almost no sense and there is
almost no contagion happening outdoors
as a general thing is very very little
so I do not believe we should be
sanitizing our streets our richer Opeth
Act says HS innately white-supremacist
why cuz white gets to go first that is
interesting I believe it is chess is
white supremacist by its very nature
zesty African says I'm a huge New Deal
Democrat guy I'll likely only be voting
for Biden if he commits to dropping the
Medicare age do you think it's likely I
thought he already did that I thought he
already said he was gonna lower it too
was it 55 or I remember he was going to
lower it by an amount that would add
about 20-something million people to the
Medicare rolls that's my recollection
Philip Carden has subscribed on YouTube
as has Pacey bean which I very much
appreciate Kohn nen Germann says love
your show David cheers from the
Netherlands love the Netherlands I've
only had the pleasure of visiting Bert
Ravel I've only visited two places in
the netherlands amsterdam and Maastricht
Amsterdam and Maastricht I went to
master it on a different trip when I was
mostly in Belgium took a train down
through Belgium and into Maastricht
great little spot and Amsterdam is just
tremendous I went to the anne frank
memorial house museum call it what you
want
did I did we rent bikes in Amsterdam I
think we didn't we didn't rent bikes but
I certainly had waffles
I had herring on the street it was
delightful really was beautiful time
okay let me say oh hold on a Joseph
Curtis says can't wait
for you to finally go on the Joe Rogan
podcast again Joe has been spreading a
lot of misinformation to his millions of
listeners please save them and shut down
the phony ant Abidin rhetoric
yeah I'm scheduled to be back on very
very soon we're in the next period of
time from the standpoint of time I am
going to be appearing there very
strongly is the way I would put it let
me say a few thank-yous to some
tremendous people Elijah
solo Ohashi is new member number two
today at join pakman.com sasha rolled is
new member number three today at join
pakman.com and liz davis hey liz is new
member number four today also thank you
to brian ashen felter who's new member
number five and cheryl Fairbrother is
new member number six love it love it
absolutely fantastic
okay ASMR sports says did you see that
Joe Rogan was calling Mackin Annie a
gangster because she had some garbage
talking point typed up for her first
press conference we'd love for you to
call that out yeah I'll talk to Joe
about that I mean listen here's the
thing
Caylee Mackin Annie is effective in that
trumpets and Trump thinks she's crushing
it that's really all that matters
that's all that matter is tweeting about
how great she is Trump loves it trumpets
think she's killing it that's really all
that matters it's just an optics game I
mean she lies about everything
she has a weaponized her perverted
version of Christianity into justifying
the means for the ends telling daily
lies I guess for whatever reason she
thinks is good to prop up Trump it's
sick but all that mad I mean listen
we're not voting for Trump anyway right
so we has completely figured out a way
to appeal to the exact people she's
supposed to appeal to appreciate the
super chat very much over on Twitch
there is a hype train going on and it
has stunningly reached level four
proportions we have colors 80
kay Reggie nerd kim.com I still am
trying to figure out whether that is the
kim.com we do follow each other on on
Twitter kim.com
again gifting 10 subscriptions to people
which I love pinchy has subscribed with
prime very very much appreciated and
it's uh it is wild what is going on on
Twitch right now very very exciting
Megan Curran says what's the over-under
on corona Kaylie raged quitting today
she raged quits every press conference I
mean every press conference when she
gets a nasty question she leaves so did
this you may find this funny last press
briefing that I covered of Kaylee's we
had an over-under for when she would
tell the first lie at three minutes and
I took the over I was stupid I said it
would take more than three minutes for
her to lie twelve seconds in she had
told her first lie so let's do a
different over-under 10 seconds okay
will it take her more than 10 seconds to
tell the first lie today or less than 10
seconds to tell the first lie we're
almost gonna have to go to like three
seconds if it's under today but I'm
gonna say I'm gonna take the over I
believe it will take her more than 10
seconds to tell the first lie today I
think she came out and said the u.s. is
leading the world in testing with the
most tests which is of course a lie we
at the time were like 42nd per capita
were now about 38th or 39th oh one other
thing let me address a talking point
that's now spreading the Trump
administration is now repeating hey we
now have more per capita testing than
South Korea that's true and it is no
longer relevant here's what is really
important to understand early on South
Korea developed the test started testing
and contact tracing and they were
obliterating the United States in per
capita testing for a long time now South
Korea did so well that the numbers have
gone down dramatically we can even look
at them actually I think we can very
easily find them here so if you look at
South Korea's numbers South Korea only
ever had 10,000 cases in 250 these
numbers are incredible and what you see
is that it's been like two months since
Korea even had cases like that they've
been under a hundred and fifty cases a
day for almost two full months so we now
have caught up to them and per-capita
testing why because our outbreak is
lasting orders of magnitude longer than
theirs so now all of a sudden Kayleigh
McKennon II interpret saying hey
everybody's bragging about South Korea
this South Korea that we've tested as
many people as them yes months later
because they no longer need testing
because nobody has coronavirus almost
nobody has coronavirus in South Korea so
please don't fall for that one please
don't fall for that one it's a
ridiculous talking point laughable
laughable okay other super shots coming
in let's see here TJ says you need to
reconsider and go on joe rogan as soon
as possible because he has such a large
influence listen the reason I wasn't on
last week was because I couldn't get a
flight out there's just no flights and
we're not supposed to be flying around
it's been rescheduled to be done
digitally or via teleconference as Trump
I'm sorry I have to sniff in between
tella conference and it should be
happening soon I hope with Joe Tony
O'Shea has subscribed on YouTube Wade
Flores says hey David glad to hear
you're going back on Rogen are you going
to discuss the misinformation that Elon
Musk was spreading on the last episode I
didn't see that episode I have to admit
so I'll review it Patrick
e has subscribed on YouTube lunchbox
says David thank you for all you do
pleasure I appreciate your support Mart
Fillion says you know what lies off of
the bat yes she'll probably come out and
lie about testing right away is my guess
at this point um okay let me say a few
other new member thank-yous these are
climbing dramatically all of a sudden I
want to say thanks to Laura macmillan
whose new member number seven today
thank you to Amanda Baker whose new
member number eight Andrew Taylor is new
member number nine today John Dalton
new member number 10 very much
appreciate that Eric Cusick is new
member number 11 and Edward Walsh is new
member number 12 so appreciate your
support you know it's it's uh there's
been a lot going on for everybody and we
have dramatically increased our content
we're doing the almost daily streams and
it's it's worth it because clearly it's
resonating with people and people are
supporting the work and not everybody is
even using the coupon code the coupon
code does save you sixty-six percent but
I see people who are foregoing the
coupon code and just saying give me the
membership at join pakman.com and i'm
not even taking the discount either way
we love it we love it okay
prime daddy has subscribed on YouTube
Matt Allen says hey David what are some
good newspapers websites or strategies
to take to be more informed in this age
of misinformation check out my entire
critical thinking miniseries that's what
I would recommend it's it's less about
an individual website but it's about
having the skills to apply critical
thinking to whatever media sources you
are consuming that that's what I would
recommend more than any particular media
outlets zesty African says who's a
better comedian Dave Rubin or Dave
Chappelle I think about them on the one
hand Dave Rubin did do that skit where
he went out and asked people in the
audience to raise their hands if they
were gay that was sort of funny on the
other hand Dave Chappelle it's really
tough guys I don't know I don't know the
answer to that now obviously I think we
all know the answer
riki ban Kemper says love your work
David you should tell Joe Rogan you do
karate that's an interesting idea I mean
it wouldn't be true I did I did have a
green belt when I was seven but since
then Karate has not been my my big thing
there's this really weird thing
happening where our website is reporting
that there are 300 people on the website
right now but if I actually look at what
pages people are on it looks like it's
only 50 people that's really weird I
hope we're not
under some kind of bizarre DDoS attack
of some kind that that would not be good
that would be very bad in fact I hope
that that's not what's going on right
now weird a couple of other thank-yous
Jack Ellsworth has signed up on my
website and his new member number 13
also Shane Olson is new member number 14
which I really appreciate
it looks like the website is operating
very very smoothly which is exciting
people asking about the written version
of the David Pakman show in the chat
yeah so here's the deal we relaunched
our daily newsletter on sub stack and
you can sign up for it at david
pakman.com it's totally free totally
totally free next week we will start the
transition from just a plain old
newsletter to a written digest of each
episode some people when people used to
commute to work in a former era of the
country a lot of people would write to
me saying you know I kind of would
rather read what's on the show in more
detail and so starting next week we are
going to start putting out this written
version of sorts of the david pakman
show and you can sign up for it for free
on my website or at david pakman.com
free free free it's all free it cost
nothing I want to be clear about that it
costs nothing well let's see here
Jacob Ratner says trumpets are tweeting
about Obama gate what is their argument
that Obama gates been going on for a
long time and it's the biggest political
crime ever perpetrated come on man get
with the times
Tyler tan says Joe I agree with whoever
is in front of me Rogan uh you know I
don't know that that's fair check out
his recent interview with Dan Crenshaw
which I analyzed John Willig says off
topic but why are people considering
stacey abrams provide ins Biden's VP
when she has so little experience I
don't think there's any chance Biden
picked Stacey Abrams I also don't know
why people think that she might be the
VP I just don't see it
JH WH says I'm no religious nut but I'm
Christian and pray for all of my fellow
people in the US
I hope that you don't lose hope despite
Trump's bad response well said bene
haidle Bach has subscribed on YouTube
Keith stone says the emperor has no
clothes the goggles they do nothing I
like that Bryan Holaday says what
exactly is contact tracing how is it
done so contact tracing would be someone
is diagnosed with kovat someone asks
them about contacts and calls them
alright let's listen in hello everyone I
want to highlight three critical aspects
of president Trump's response to the
coronavirus that have exceeded the
media's expectations and should inspire
confidence in every American across this
country rest assured the Trump
administration is working tirelessly to
defeat the invisible enemy first
contrary to some media pronouncements
the United States did not need the 1
million ventilators thus far the media
said we okay so she didn't lie in the
first 10 seconds she wins or you guys
win every single American who has needed
a ventilator has received a ventilator
that's a lot and this administration has
managed to procure excuse me 100,000
ventilators to be man manufactured in
100 days that's extraordinary that's 3
times the amount produced in the average
year likewise there was some concern
about n95 respirators but the Trump
administration has now shipped over 90
million in 95 respirators once again the
number they've been using for weeks by
the way weird bridge healthcare industry
consumption of n95 respirators beautiful
year finally the US now leads the world
in testing for weeks the media like I
did South Korea as being the gold
standard for tech you all know we are
now testing at a higher rate per capita
than South Korea because they have no
cases because they solved this six weeks
ago in all 50 states we are now testing
at a higher rates per capita than South
Korea I told you guys state in this
country is testing at a high this is why
we would do the pre-show you were all
prepared for the South Korea Lai
extraordinary I would say
now I would like to provide the American
people with an update on the Trump
administration support for underserved
communities as the president has said
this country's at war with the invisible
enemy and while we all fight the virus
as one United American people it is a
fact that this virus disproportionately
has affected those and medically
underserved communities and therefore
the president has committed to
delivering economic supports in quality
care for individuals and distressed
communities the Trump administration as
I announced last week distributed 12
billion dollars and provider relief
payments to 395 hospitals across the
country that have been hearted hardest
hit by the corona virus many of these
hospitals were in underserved
communities and to ensure even more
funding to these communities two billion
dollars of that overall funding was
specifically targeted to hospitals in
proportion to the amount of care they
provide for low-income and uninsured
patients additionally the Trump
administration is investing nearly two
billion dollars in community health
centers to help their 28 million
patients and medically underserved areas
that receive care and the testing they
need that's what this funding is
intended for and additionally there's
583 million awarded to a thousand three
hundred eighty five health centers in
all 50 states the District of Columbia
and the eight US territories
specifically geared towards tessalata
gobbledy these health centers currently
provide a hundred thousand tests per
week and fifty-nine percent of the
patients tested last week were from
minority communities finally under the
Paycheck protection program the Trump
administration has done extensive
outreach to the community development
financial institution funds across the
countries these are known as CDF eyes
and they support revitalization and
distress communities in the second round
of PPP 100,000 loans have been
distributed to CDF eyes into m.d eyes
which are known as minority deposit
institutions these have amounted to
about 6.2 billion dollars and finally
570 thousand seven hundred twenty three
loans have been issued to smaller
lenders and non banks and these loans
have amount
- twenty nine point nine billion dollars
President Trump will continue to fight
for the health safety and economic
well-being of all Americans especially
those impacted in low-income communities
and disadvantaged communities and with
that I'll take questions yes yesterday
said the US had prevailed on testing but
today we heard from senators both
Democratic and Republican who say that's
not the case senator Lamar Alexander a
Republican says what our country has
done so far in testing is impressive but
not nearly enough she has to play her
patty Murray at Democrats that we need
dramatically more testing as
unacceptable we don't have a national
strategic plan what's the White House
response well first I would notes on the
words of dr. Anthony Falchi which is
this we will have and there will be
enough tests to allow us to take this
country safely through phase one I've
sat in some of the worst meetings where
admirals wah has talked to governor's
and literally pulled out his chart and
said governor X here was your plan and
your request for testing in order to
safely reopen I can assure you that that
will be satisfied this month so I have
seen those meetings take place I can
assure the American people in line with
what dr. Fauci has said we do have
enough for phase 1 by the end of the
week we'll be able to say that we've
conducted 10 million tests you know we
went from doing 150,000 that's a
meaningless number 10 million I mean ok
oh is that a lot is it not a lot what
does that really mean to also note that
that's 2 times what we're what other
countries are doing when you look at
America's testing I'd say that that's
pretty impressive and that's a testament
to the work of this administration and
the hard work of the private sector and
also vaccines if you don't mind
first of all reopening schools there
were a lot of questions today up on the
hill about when indeed that can happen
when for the White House and will the
White House issued guidance benchmarks
for various communities and then on when
that can happen and how soon that can
happen there's a lot of concerned
parents as you know across the country
yeah well you know in our guidelines to
safely reopen that that are data-driven
it is phase 3 where there is an outline
to beginning to open schools states are
going to phase one without even meeting
the guidelines to do it so states don't
follow it it's kind of worthless I
didn't study is in the works that is
forthcoming
we'll provide additional details
vaccines the question was asked when
when and if a vaccine becomes available
regardless of income can the president
ensure that everybody will get the
vaccine regardless of income well if the
president will go to great efforts to
ensure that I don't want to get ahead of
any announcement on his part but I would
say this that when it came to testing
there was that same question what if I'm
uninsured and don't have the ability to
afford a test this president before it
was even addressed in Congress called in
the private sector and got companies to
say yes we will cover both treatment and
we will cover testing and then
eventually that was inscribed into law
um so this president before it was even
an issue on the hill took great measures
with testing and he will do the same for
vaccines and I would just note as dr.
Falchi said on the hill today there are
eight vaccine candidates and on January
10th we received the genetic sequence
the 11th there was a plan developed the
14th development began and 62 days later
we entered phase 1 clinical trials for
vaccine which is the fastest ever and
dr. fauci's knowledge at least so that's
a pretty good pace that I think note
that that is none of that has anything
to do with Trump right room desert fear
try me none of this stuff has anything
to do with Trump in April will he work
with them encourage them to make sure
that vaccines are affordable to everyone
absolutely there's no doubt about it yes
we do first I'm reopening here we got
your Falchi today stress many times the
reopening without following the federal
thank you I have a couple questions
first I'm reopening dr. Falchi today
stress many times that reopening without
following the federal guidelines and the
gating criteria could lead to more
outbreaks and could turn back the clock
this president Trump's still believe in
these federal guidelines and if so why
isn't he
urging states to follow them yeah
they're not asking them to move quickly
to reopen well he has encouraged States
to follow the guidelines that's still
consistently our recommendation today
that use a phased approach to reopening
as outlined in the data I do want to
stress as the president has stressed
that we do want to reopen this country
because there are consequences that run
the other way when we stay close down as
a country and I want to run through a
few of those with you
a hotline run by the substance abuse and
mental health services saw a 1000%
increase in responses during April as we
kept this country so they're gonna do
the thing now about you know suicides
and stuff like that which Trump never
cared about before let me just remind
you guys of the states that have opened
almost none of them met what we're
called the three phase one guidelines to
go to phase one you were supposed to
meet a whole bunch of guidelines most of
the states that have opened never met
those so so like what what is the point
of those guidelines even see as many
people in the halls and that is quite
frightening because the consequence of
that is this according to the iqv ia
Institute for human data science a total
of 80,000 plus diagnoses of five common
cancers and the United States are
protected are projected to be missed or
delayed during the three-month period of
early March to early June which is why
this president has always said go to
your doctor do your screenings there's a
way to safely do this if you feel chest
pain go to your doctor we can't scare
people from going to hospitals it's a
consequence of staying close though when
people are scared they're scared to even
go to their doctor and there are
consequences for that and finally I
would just point out recent CNN article
from Friday noted a National Public
Health Group that warned as many as
75,000 Americans could die because of
drug or alcohol misuse and suicide as a
result of the corona virus pandemic so
there are consequences to us
closed and it's why I believe it was
eight Medical Group's came out with a
statement eight Medical Group's noted
concerns that some people with symptoms
of heart attack stroke and cardiac
arrest are avoiding hospitals so it's
why I've said from this podium I think
at least two times today is the second
or third you've got to go to your doctor
we've got to encourage to this country
to safely reopen said it would be
nonsensical to test all Americans and
yesterday the administration celebrated
testing 2.7 percent of the population in
order to reopen 100 percent of the
country what amount of testing does make
sense to you and what's an alternative
to testing to track and contain not
gonna get a virus to make people feel
confident to get back to normal sure we
have to engage in strategic testing
which is what our experts have always
said look you know yet Admirals wha-hoo
said it's a bad strategy to say that you
need to test everyone because testing a
person now just means they're negative
at this moment a point also emphasized
by doctor Falchi if you get a test today
that does not mean that tomorrow or the
next day or the next day or the next day
you might get exposed which is why we
acknowledge testing is not preventive
what is preventive is wearing this mask
what is preventive is social distancing
what is preventable but it's not totally
accurate because if you test a lot of
asymptomatic people and they find out
they're positive they can then isolate
and it is preventive so so she's it's
not true which is it's just not true I'm
trying to think of another way to say it
it's a lie deployed and I stand by the
comment that I made earlier yes
next round of Corona fire run by
responding the bell that the speaker is
releasing today what provisions are
no-go for the administration what can
you get behind look I won't get ahead of
the President and negotiating but and I
certainly won't condition any future
legislation on a certain proposal but I
will say that the president has noted a
payroll tax is something that he's
looked at not conditioning it on that
but noting that something he desires to
see in its smart policy in fact
according to Steven Warren art Laffer
this means quota every worker in America
would get substantial pay raise up
sports so promising about the payroll
tax is that it's a regressive tax so the
lowest wage workers are in fact the ones
who would be most help because they pay
more payroll tax than they do income tax
so that's something the president's
mentioned not necessarily as a condition
I won't negotiate here with speaker
Pelosi but I encourage her to work with
the president help these low income
individuals get this tax cut that they
deserve
Michael Pak has a confirmation hearing
on Thursday could you speak to what the
president wants him to do it confirm to
change the way the voice of America
operates yeah I won't get ahead of that
hearing which is later in the week as
there's no idea I won't ask you about
the task force the president the vice
president said last week that there be
some new additions to the task force and
that those would be announced on Monday
we haven't seen those names
giving you update on that and whether
there are going to in fact we people
have is that task force yeah there will
be additions but no announcements on
that just maybe Newt Gingrich Jeff
[Music]
Petersburg today from ventilators
Russian ventilators that explode it I'm
wondering whether you can add them to
the Russian ventilators that were sent
to the United States and whether those
ventilators have been used and if not if
they're or so if they're being taken wow
that's insane
that's the first time hearing of that
story so I don't have any updates on
that other than to note that we are way
ahead of where we should be on
ventilators as I noted in my opening
remarks a hundred thousand ventilators
one hundred days is really good and no
one has died for lack of events later
but that's the first time doesn't lie
that's a lie lie lie
yesterday the president indicated that
he might be communicating with vice
president tents by phone for a while
while the vice president keeps some
distance can you give us an update on
whether or not those two men are going
to see each other in person or whether
the I know the vice president has been
working at the White House is he keeping
his distance from the president for a
while now the vice president has made
the choice to keep his distance for a
few days and I would just note that
that's his personal decision to make
that goes to how many days he does it
again that's a decision for the vice
president yes I've got a related
question Wednesday
time that we might see dr. Bergson dr.
Falchi here in this room now giving us
an update I'm kind of the status of the
public health regarding front of iris
look we've heard from dr. Fauci pretty
much the entirety of the day he had a
hearing as you noted so you've probably
heard from him more hours today then
than you've ever heard from dr. foul to
you you hear from these experts
regularly out on television and you know
we'll see the next time they're up here
in this capacity but they certainly have
valued their time and we continue to
value their time it's been a while since
we've seen dr. Berg so for example I
mean she is the coordinator the
coronavirus task force when when when we
see her and be able to get get an update
from her and be able to ask questions of
her forget it yeah again you know I I
don't know when in this capacity you
will see her but I talked to dr. Burks
regularly in fact I talked to her just
before I came out here excited some
questions about some funny numbers I
heard from senator Elizabeth Warren and
she helped me to correct those numbers
are you about to correct here because I
think it's unfair to the American people
to give inflated case numbers and
mortality numbers because it leads to
those same Americans my question was
when we would see dr. Burke's mcgrann to
not have the cancer screenings they need
so I'd like to just reveal to you some
information dr. Burke's to share that
was Elizabeth Warren erroneously said
there were 25,000 new cases today in
fact there were less than 20,000 senator
Warren said there were 2,000 deaths in
fact there have been less than a
thousand I spoke with dr. Burks about
that so I'd encourage our Democratic
colleagues and all Americans to make
sure we're putting out there good
information because it does have
consequences
Justice Department is considering
bringing federal charges against the two
men charged with murdering Ahmad our
brief does the president think that's
appropriate
look I'd refer you to the Department of
Justice statement which is this that we
are considering the request of the
Attorney General of Georgia and have
asked that he forward to federal
authorities any information that he has
about the handling of that investigation
will continue to assess all information
and will take any appropriate action
that is warranted by the facts in the
law and the president I've heard him say
it to me personally his heart breaks for
the family of a Matar burry and we want
to see justice in that case as the facts
lead us to that place yes yes they also
wear marks around the West Wing except
when they were seated at their desks I
can't help but make this you want to
wear any moss no it's because I'm
distanced from you you'd probably have a
hard time hearing from me right now
should I have a mask on and not be
muffled on delivering information to the
American people I'm an appropriate
distance away I had a negative test
today I had a negative test yesterday
and I'm in an okay place yes
Afghanistan one night well present her
from Barney for his troops on an
offensive footing from spoken to him
about that what does it mean for the
u.s. with peace process not that I'm
aware of and I don't have any new
information on that yes White House
report on locations to watch and with
increased cases he said locations to
locations to watch with increased cases
we're seeing rates spiking in several
spots in the Midwest included in Kansas
City is this a concern about this just
before coming out and I think you're
referring to a document that was put out
that wasn't a White House document it
was a FEMA document that looked at what
was going on in the Midwest and she made
the point to me she showed me a document
that showed that these are isolated
outbreaks that where there are specific
instances and let's say a meat
processing facility or a prison where we
isolate that there's a problem we're
able to contact trace and pretty quickly
resolve this guys everything's fine we
shouldn't be worried that Texas Florida
Georgia and places that ridiculed the
closings are now becoming the places
with the fastest case increases
everything's fine system is working that
were able to identify what the president
said our embers and put them out on it's
the system at work not closing people
not going to medical appointments but
how do you extend that argument to
restaurants nail salons you know
barbershops and beauty are those things
kind of essential things you're talking
about what I'm talking about is we have
a phase plan to reopen and you can
follow those guidelines and the
restaurants are in phases and then
artainment facilities you noted are in
phases as accordance with declining
cases but as a whole with the totality
of the circumstances when you have a
society that's shut down people are
locked in their homes and they're
isolated it leads to the very suicide
line increased calls that I had noted it
leads to drug abuse there are
consequences to eternally staying shut
down which is why you have to remember
no one's suggesting eternally being shut
down
if we did a proper 60 days shutdown on
March 5th they'd be over by now and we
would be reopening things vision for
America going forward he made the right
decision to shut down the country at the
time he did because there were 2.2
million lives
remember Trump didn't make that decision
in fact it started being made by a whole
bunch of Governors and even after Trump
asked for it many governors never did it
now it's read the lies are coming fast
and furious now dr. Falchi made today he
said I think we were going in the right
direction but the right direction does
not mean we have by any means total
control of this outbreak how does that
square with the president's statement
yesterday that we have prevailed great
well the president made clear he was
talking about testing the fact that we
can say we're doing a lot of any other
country the fact that we can put up a
graph that shows South Korea is a small
little red bar of testing per capita and
every bar beside it is an American state
or territory out doing what South Korea
has done in South Korea has Korea was
the gold standard for testing in fact on
March they're six weeks ago they don't
have cases anymore - South Korea is
doing 10,000 coronavirus tests a day the
u.s. is struggling for even a small
fraction of that and here we are on may
11th with a Washington Post headline the
administration keeps bragging that the
u.s. testing now is better than South
Korea's was a month ago so you can't
demand that we reach South Korea and say
that we're bragging when we do this is a
moment where the American private sector
succeeded this administration mobilized
that testing every state is better off
than South Korea at this movement and
that is a very good thing and something
to celebrate American innovation at its
best with 92 emergency use authorization
on its this administration under
President Trump working agree with dr.
Falchi that we do not have total control
over this outbreak the president
believes in the phase guidelines to
reopening which doctor felt she signed
off on along with dr. Burks and we
encourage every state and government
follow yes thank you daily the president
said
that Florida has so much testing that
testers are literally sitting around
waiting for people and that there is a
quote great overcapacity yet the reality
in the state is there are still
widespread criticism reports of not
enough testing they might have Kaiser
Family Foundation ranks four to twenty
fourth in the country per capita when it
comes to testing so is the president
being overly optimistic about the
situation in Florida not in the
slightest I was actually in the Oval
Office when that discussion transpired
and the governor of Florida governor de
santis who's doing a phenomenal job
talked about that there were there was
over testing at the local sites so there
were extra tests there wasn't enough
demand there weren't people showing up
to use them all he said that that had
happened around some sites in the states
he saw it firsthand he's the governor of
Florida and that's a good thing and
we're able to fulfill governor DeSantis
plan in full that he has laid out as
necessary to reopening the state of
Florida which happens to be my great
home state yes does not support that
Kaleigh so is the president just
listening to the governor or is he
looking at the data oh he's looking at
the data as I noted to You Admiral schwa
has a chart of every single governor's
plan and has said we will fulfill every
single governor's plan governor DeSantis
what do you concede that Florida's 24th
and in testing is the question through
testing sites with the restarting of the
economies on both sides of the Canadian
and US border you know how much trade
between the two sides are essential for
community here's our favorite can you
update us on the plans for reopening and
also a timeline for reopening the border
yeah no announcements on that front
today yep shanell
least of the transcripts related to data
chips Russian probe this week is there
any information you can share with us as
to what the DOJ has shared the White
House on whether it is investigating
Obama administration officials on this
matter so I don't have any updates on
that front because that's currently a
DOJ matter but you did refer to
transcripts and I do think it's an
important moment to talk about what was
in some of the transcripts that were
released probes ones that you're asking
about but we learned from newly released
transcripts a few things we learned that
with some Obama officials were saying
publicly it was much different than what
they were saying privately James clapper
was out there saying that he had
evidence that this was worse than
Watergate on when in fact a few weeks
later he was saying privately I never
saw any direct empirical evidence that
the Trump campaign or someone in it so
this is not even related to the question
and the question was not even clear to
the person asking it funny story about
so that's the oen reporter Chanel Ryan
she reportedly has been walking around
the White House with her own chair like
she tries to get her own folding chair
from what I've read into these because
she doesn't actually have a seat and it
still remains a question in terms of the
security situation of how she doesn't
have a seat but she's still honestly I
don't get it but reportedly she's been
walking around with with a folding chair
if you can imagine something more
visually absurd collusion that these
Obama administration officials never
existed they never saw any evidence of
but for three years the American people
were dragged through the mud and told
that their choice for the President of
the United States might have been a
Russian asset based on no evidence of
all at all this president was exonerated
by the Moller report that's a lot I mean
there's some real qumola report said we
cannot exonerate Trump on obstruction of
justice that's a little direct line
privately thank you so much I think I
got to all of you and we'll be back soon
there it is wrapping up wow what an
event
what an event ladies and gentlemen I
think there were probably I mean it's
like if you ask me now how many lies
total were there I don't know the number
I mean I guess there were probably
Ford it like is 40 lies reason 235 lot I
don't know I'd have to really go through
with a fine-tooth comb maybe tomorrow I
would actually whatever the next one is
make note of each lie or distortion but
I mean it's like I guess about there a
few dozen lies we're told it was only
like a 25 minute press conference again
people asking for name one lie okay one
lie would be the molar report completely
exonerated Trump that's directly not
true another lie would be no one died
from lack of a ventilator we know of at
least a few situations where that is
certainly questionable at minimum you
know we could go on and on and on their
lies about testing lies about you you
know taking credit for things that have
nothing to do with Trump deflecting
blame I mean you know some are direct
lies some are deceptions somewhere
doublespeak there's all sorts of
different stuff okay let's see I do want
to make sure that I say thank you to
Thomas carder Ella mark Knives Jonatan
Miguel resada Sanchez Janet Levinson and
Susan Gunther very very much appreciated
I am going to go directly outside right
now and I am going to put on my
Instagram right now okay so if you
follow me on instagram you will see this
my cucumbers have sprouted my friends my
cucumbers have sprouted in my
coronavirus Victory Garden that's it for
the stream follow me on instagram at
david pakman in 10 minutes you'll be
able to see my cukes I'm going to show
everybody my cukes thank you for joining
me
you